Welcome back! Now,
Beyoncé's visual album Lemonade
has caused quite a stir
on the Internet,
sparking all sorts
of controversies, think pieces,
and Twitter beefs. So here
to sort through all the drama
is Nightly Show Contributor
Franchesca Ramsey
with her segment Hash It Out.
-(tweeting)
-♪ ♪
Thanks, Larry. Yep, this week
has been all about Lemonade.
Beyoncé's new visual album is
the musical journey of a woman
scorned by her cheating husband.
Because as the saying goes,
when life hands you lemons,
drag your (bleep)
cheating husband
and collect your Grammys.
That is, before Kanye tries to
collect those Grammys for you.
Personally, I loved Lemonade.
But, obviously,
when Beyoncé drops an album,
there's one person
we all want to hear from,
one oracle of wisdom
who can cut through the noise
and elevate this celebration
of black womanhood
to its proper place.
I'm talking, of course,
about failed CNN host
Piers Morgan.
So, what did Piers Morgan
have to say?
Let's take a look
at some of his tweets.
"To clarify, I love Beyoncé
and Lemonade's a great album.
"I just didn't like
the politically/racially charged
video that went with it."
So Piers is mad
because the music video
for the song "Freedom"
includes the mothers
of Trayvon Martin, Eric Garner,
and Michael Brown.
It's a sad but powerful moment
in a song
about overcoming the odds
and fighting for what's right.
And, apparently, advocating
for black lives
gets Piers' knickers in a twist.
I said "knickers," you guys.
I'm not some sort
of Piers Morgan over here.
His next tweet says,
"I've always been consistently
against gun control.
"Beyoncé's
suddenly turned political.
There's a difference." Sure,
you've consistently been
against gun control.
You've also consistently been
a juice-- douche bag.
First off,
music has always been political.
Ever heard of Bob Marley
or John Lennon
or Bill Clinton playing sax
on Arsenio?
As far as I'm concerned,
Beyoncé's music
has always been political.
"Bills, Bills, Bills"
was clearly about
raising the minimum wage.
"Single Ladies," the ultimate
marriage equality theme song.
"Crazy in Love" about funding
m-mental health infrastructure.
"Freakum Dress,"
reforming tariffs on textiles
for clothing manufacturers.
And "Partition," well,
that one's just about (bleep)
in a limousine.
(cheering and applause)
But as the Internet does,
people felt they needed
to jump into the conversation
and cosign this foolishness
totally uninvited.
"I agree with Piers Morgan.
"I'm black and I believe
Beyoncé has exploited our race
"for album sales.
Let her prove she hasn't
by donating."
Um, prove it? How?
Oh, you mean like the millions
she spent to help victims
of Hurricane Katrina?
Or her benefit concerts
for Haiti?
Or her contributions to bail out
the Black Lives Matter activists
in Ferguson and Baltimore.
Not to mention
all that stage time she donated
to Coldplay
during the Super Bowl.
(cheering and applause)
Come on.
Seriously.
But back to Piers Morgan,
'cause, of course,
he wasn't done.
"Am I even allowed to listen
to Beyoncé's new album
"given my white skin color?
I'm confused." Yeah.
Well, I'm confused by the way
British people spell "color."
And you can absolutely enjoy
Lemonade. And you should.
But you also have to realize
that this album isn't about you.
That's why Beyoncé featured
an ultimate black girl squad
including Serena Williams.
If Lemonade was about you,
Piers Morgan,
it would have been called
Metamucil.
(laughter, applause
and cheering)
Look, Piers,
it's like if you try to wear
a pair of apple bottom jeans.
-(laughter)
-Sure, you can get them on.
But without a big booty,
they might not fit that well.
(laughter)
It doesn't mean
that you can't wear them,
but you're gonna have
a hard time
feeling totally comfortable,
because they weren't created
for your comfort.
So if you're cool with that,
then go ahead
and get into formation.
And if you're not,
then in the words of Beyoncé,
"Please, suck my balls."
(cheers and applause)
Franchesca Ramsey, everybody.
We'll be right back. Man. Whew!